and now on to our first topic the Pope
versus the Vatican in this week
spectator Damien Thompson reveals what's
really going on in Pope Francis's
pontificate we've seen already that he's
very charismatic Pope he captures the
attention of non-christians world why
he's come back from a very successful
tour of firm South Korea but when he's
back in Rome what is he up to Damien
says is nothing less than a complete
overhaul of the Vatican structure and an
attempt to do away with the influence of
the Italian Cardinals who killed his
predecessors papacy Damien that's quite
some stuff you got in the magazine this
week what to the outsider might be what
we see to a paper see which is being
redefined is this all the internal
workings of the Vatican or is I think I
think the whole point of this
pontificate is to clean up the Vatican
that is why Cardinal bergoglio was
elected I don't think the Goblin
realized that he was going to become
this enormously charismatic figure who
cultivated the press but it is important
not I think to be distracted by lots of
the attention-grabbing and often
contradictory things of Francis says
hinting at you know new attitudes
towards homosexuality or or marriage
they aren't going to happen it's not on
his agenda his big agenda is to clean up
the Vatican he's basically declared war
on the Curia the Vatican particularly
the Italian mafia who destroyed the
pontificate of his predecessor benedict
the sixteen how do they destroy tickets
well Benedict rather unwisely put far
too much power in the hands of his
secretary state sort of Prime Minister
Cardinal Bertone II one of the things
bitoni did was that he oversaw the
Vatican
banky oversaw a lot of the financial
dealings of the church and he wasted a
lot of money and it was a suspicion that
he was far too close and that many of
his fellow Cardinals and bishops and
Kiril officials were far too close too
sleazy Italian businessman are we
talking about criminality hero are not
necessarily talking about criminality
but what we're talking about is a cozy
way of doing business bye you know
Cardinals whose management of money is
about a skillful a set of the Reverend
Paul flowers of the coop bank in this
country basically so that I had to write
off a really really big investment by
buitoni which he'd made despite
everybody he's a professional advice to
the contrary so while process is done
this is freaked out the Liberals a bit
is that he's created a new Vatican
department which has complete control of
the church's finances and he's put in
charge of it as prefect Cardinal George
Pell was one of the most conservative
Cardinals in the college the glamour
change skipper he's a climate-change
skeptic he was head of the church in
Australia and he's come over and taken
over this new body and from now on
nobody will be allowed to to do deals as
an individual and pail is going to
appoint an independent auditor and
everything will be rigorously budgeted
and he'll be advised by highly
successful people from the anglosphere
now pearls given interviews in which he
kind of hints that there's a financial
expertise in the anglosphere that he he
values and he's also said rather
interesting comment that he thought it
was a not necessarily good thing that
Benedict ended up with more Italian
Cardinals but he started with is it the
Protestant work ethic coming to Rome
that's what's actually happening I don't
think you I think perhaps as a touch of
the Protestant work I think about pearl
although he wouldn't like the web
Protestant because the Australian church
is actually very tribal yeah but there's
certainly a work I think there he's he's
immensely clever he's got lots of
doctors he's so much brighter than
the vast majority of grim dismal dragon
spouting English bishops who are not not
very highly regarded deliver Freddie you
were in Rome and before the Pope's
elation and and it's funny that nothing
is more political than the Vatican of
that sort of time was there a sense then
that you needed a regime change at the
Vatican which went deeper than just a
new personality that you need that you
needed a new mechanism and that this
election was about sweeping out an old
order and replacing it with in you
definitely definitely I mean you just
had this bombshell of Benedict resigning
and everybody I spoke to a liberal
conservative tradition is progressive
whatever whatever type of Catholic they
were they were all adamant that the
Curia was the problem something's got to
be done to fix this rot at the heart of
the church and this rot I mean was it
just simply about leaking money I mean
while terrible but doesn't sound that
scandalous well it's always very hard to
get to the truth of it there's there's
always some very you know that the
Italian papers will publish this
incredibly sensational stuff about you
know kind of gay Mathias and there's the
sort of stuff you read in The Da Vinci
Code you know but while all that's
exaggerated there's certainly corruption
in there they're sort of favors being
carried out within the Vatican bankin
and then of course there's the political
abuse problem which was very badly
handled by the Curia for a couple of
decades and that the people I spoke to
was quite interesting as they all
thought that it's such a nip Italian
problem that you need an Italian to come
in and fix it and then of course we have
begun gu who is who was sort of Italian
but he's actually happening I I think he
understands Italians he speaks the
language fernley actually what his
problem is that he doesn't speak English
he's never been to America that he's
going to go there he's known me to this
country as far as I know so in Latin
America and he is a very
figure the priests he sees evangelizing
successfully have all their hands dirty
in the slums tend to be very left with
leaning and bigelow himself has moved in
that direction having been a very
conservative leader your generation
theology he used to clamp down on the
Roche ontology now he favors aspects of
it because he says these are the priests
who work and concerns it in Latin
America not very effective or very nice
in the atmosphere in America and in in
Britain and in Australia it's
conservative priests who get their hands
dirty who work hard who evangelized and
also who tend to build congregations so
bill congregations and you know the big
crisis and this has been this has been
confirmed to me by extremely senior
people in room in the big crisis in the
English church is that you have a map
here of the mediocre and is it the
impression that this is what frustrated
/ Benedict that he basically decided
that he can do anything with his papacy
because the Curia the guys beneath them
were unbeatable I mean I was at the
impression of the Pope was an absolute
monarch who could do pretty much what he
wanted well he could I I think a lot of
conservatives feel a bit let down by the
way Benedict who was really too old I
think great man in many ways great
reformer in liturgical responds and he
was really too old when he became Pope
he's also rather kind is called a
Rottweiler not the Rottweiler is the
Rottweiler is Francis not Benedict
actually and and he couldn't cope with
the escalating scandals many of which
involved people who were close to him or
their deadly opponents and the
factionalism just got him and he went
away and wrote books this Pope has
decided to bypass the Italian mafia
vatican by appointing a cabinet of
cardinals from around the world and it's
a kind of mess i think in some ways but
it does mean this change power will be
devolved to individual bishops
conferences which if you look at how
awful the english bridges conferences
dub may not seem like good news but
actually the non ce o--'s the Pope's
ambassadors run by the secretary of
state are pretty useless the important
thing it's been stressful me by senior
people in Rome is that the Italians who
killed and this is the word they use
killed the pontiff event of burned in
the 16th have gone and they're not
coming back right but Freddie I mean if
you're going to be in Rome taking on
Italian Cardinals it's pretty daunting
task isn't it so means you think Pope
Francis stands any more of a chance that
then Benedict it well I think yes and
partly because he's got this sort of
huge popular following behind so yes I
think he'd this is this is a golden
opportunity because there's this is such
a widespread feeling of the enough's
enough the resignation of Benedict was
proof that the system is totally rotten
so I think this is a golden opportunity
whether he can do it is a where the hell
can do it for him is it is a difficult
question to answer but pals already done
a lot yeah an interlude my notice oh my
goodness yes I mean you know he's set up
he's I mean diddly it's not just pail
but these stretch structures have been
set up for him so how will we know if
Pope Francis is triumphed then and has
actually managed to to sweep out the
fueled Curia and get rid of it are you
are we going to have lots of
argentineans wandering around instead of
Italian we do there's already lots of
Latin Americans running around being
making a quite a nuisance of themselves
saying oh well we are simple people you
know we're returning the church to the
gospel and this is of course driving
people in the Curia mad and I can kind
of understand what by and large it
doesn't work how we measure success well
actually if you look at pearls
department you will see that will be
balance sheets you will see whether
money is being generated because they've
got to generate money in order to spend
it you'll see where it is being spent is
it being spent on proper missionary
activity on advantage
ization or is it being dribbled away on
climate change activism well we see lots
of Italians being sort of sacked thrown
out of the Vatican well I'd I'll be
sidelined lots of quite a few Italians
who advised but financial advisors /
priests have have been sacked but I
think what we what we will see is the
end of a culture of you know stuffing
your face in the in the in a trattoria
and quietly arranging you know the
setting up of a dodgy charity hell was
trying to light onto that that's a great
thing if France can achieve that that's
marvelous you think and also another
thing I mentioned in just very briefly
in the article if you can reform the
Jesuits he'll have achieved a lot even
if as he said this week I shall be
gathered to the house of my father in
three or four years time which is a
typical site using Francis comment